hello and welcome everyone we're gonna
start here in just a couple more minutes
and uh in the moment as you are
preparing for this we welcome you to
check the chat on chat you will find
some information on how to best use this
time and uh also join us
um on our social media if you want to
stay connected and if you want to join
our group that can help help you find
opportunities in this industry
all right welcome everyone to this
session today we're going to talk about
our upcoming program called
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and before we jump into the program
details I want to introduce briefly who
we are and what we do
so onyxlogic is a training portal that
connects biology and data science and we
are very focused on making sure that
those who are learning about
bioinformatics or data science and
application to biological data are
equipped with their necessary skills and
experience that they can speak about
what they can do how they can apply it
to different types of challenges and how
to use it one of our major objectives
with omics logic is to address the
question of how structured
uh and how organized and systematized is
this curriculum in the domain of
bioinformatics as you all know there's a
lot of free resources available on
bioinformatics that you can find online
there are many uh free videos and
courses and kind of uh different kinds
of tutorials and what we want to do is
to really help biologists that already
understand this domain understand the
kinds of questions that are being asked
get the most out of their training spend
as little time as needed to acquire
skills that they will actually use and
then develop a portfolio of projects
that they can demonstrate in application
to the challenges that they understand
from a biological perspective
so as a result of working over the past
several years we have developed a series
of based line uh training in different
omics data types
including introduction to bioinformatics
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and a more advanced course
on data science and we kind of took that
approach and applied it to several
different domains like oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
then finally agriculture or
biotechnology
now our approach is to make it
accessible to people that have no
background whatsoever in engineering
coding or bioinformatics and so we
organize the coursework and skill
acquisition according to the stage that
you are at
um so assuming that you have no previous
experience how do you actually start
accumulating the kind of experience and
skills that you need to really be
successful in this field and um all of
this is bundled together with different
features that I will briefly describe in
today's session and then if you have any
additional questions I welcome you to
um and to actually try out this platform
and so before we go on I welcome you to
complete your profile so all of you can
for free register on the portal it is
learn.omexlogic.com
and you can join our growing community
of professionals students and
researchers from around the world we
have over 20 000 participants from top
universities in the US and other places
and we welcome you to join them by
trying out some of the features that we
have built and tell us what you like
what you don't like and how we can
really make it more useful
so our team behind this portal really is
powered by both our vision the founders
that had the vision to develop this
resource and to make it available but
also our team and and I want to mention
a few people uh sparsh Dar is our
marketing and sales team leader
Marketing sales team and she's going to
be available if you want to contact her
for any additional information about
this program or other programs that we
have going on her email is marketing at
omxlogic.com
so the Onyx logic portal really seeks to
address three major goals we want to
provide training that enable independent
research Guided by mentors in peer
example we also want to build a
community and we have a growing
community of over 20 000 participants
and we want to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data scientists
and one of the major applications of
such skills and and this domain in
general is in Precision medicine which
is what we will talk about today so as
we discuss the various topics and the
associated resources that we have
available to learn and master the skills
in application to Precision medicine
we'll really talk about how we can
connect these molecular level details
that are apparent in the genomic or omic
data in general with clinical insights
how are they used what kinds of
achievements can we see that data has
produced in these domains and we'll
touch briefly on several examples
primarily around the domain of oncology
so if you have joined us for the first
time we'd love to get to know you during
today's session feel free to add your
questions in the chat and I will be
addressing those as we go through the
next few slides also as I mentioned if
you have any questions at the end of the
session I'll be here to answer any of
them during this webinar and I hope that
you can actually connect to some of the
topics that we'll discuss and join us
for the next few
sessions that we have prepared around
some of these topics
so the
Precision medicine program is really
focused on four different sections the
first one is kind of at the level of
understanding you know what are clinical
and molecular data that are used today
in Precision medicine what does it mean
and how are they used you know in
different domains
then we'll talk briefly about the types
of molecular data that are most commonly
used and how are they used to inform
these kinds of questions and decisions
that clinicians have to make and that
will include genomics transcriptomics
and metagenomics all four or all three
of these are widely used to understand
guide and select their appropriate
treatment we'll also talk about how
these kinds of insights are
transitioning from the lab to the clinic
what are some challenges and
opportunities both in research Discovery
and then also in clinical use cases and
what how are they different and what are
some of the challenges in research and
what are some of the challenges in
actually application
and then we'll talk about some case
studies what are some data sets we've
curated that you can start using to
understand uh how this type of data
could be used in genetic diseases or
inherited oncology and infectious
diseases and that's not limited to this
short list but we have a library of
resources that are curated according to
different disciplines that you can
explore
let's start from the beginning
so first of all how is molecular data in
forming clinical decisions or how is it
related to clinical data that is
commonly being used by clinicians in the
clinic so the clinical data really
describes these symptoms and the disease
symptoms are kind of organized around
major groups so we call different
diseases by different names we can
further kind of specify their stages or
maybe their variation according to the
patient's background but the underlying
sort of pool of data that could inform
the clinical
diagnosis are these omics data sets that
really tell us at a molecular
subcellular level what is happening with
this individual at this particular time
and what does that mean in terms of a
very precise diagnosis
and how does that describe the biology
that actually defines what that clinical
phenotype is so when a clinician looks
at the clinical data these additional
Amex data types have the potential to
answer some of the more specific
questions that they might have and help
them make better more precise accurate
decisions about what to do next
let's take a look at how this plays out
in such a field like oncology where we
have a growing burden of cancer around
the world
so cancer incidence and mortality has
been growing particularly associated
with older age which is uh kind of
characterizing this Western uh world you
can see U.S Canada and Australia kind of
dominating
um how that population which is
increasingly older
um and what is the incidence so you can
see that approximately four to six
percent in these more advanced countries
have in 2017
can have incidence of cancer
and it is the second uh dominant disease
after cardiovascular diseases
um and one of the reasons for that is
because cancer is associated with cell
division and therefore we kind of tend
to see older people uh that you know
have more cells that have been dividing
for a long time
um they tend to lead to cancer and one
of the major opportunities in terms of
cancer is to try to identify the onset
of cancer earlier on now that poses a
specific challenge which is associated
with screening and apparently healthy
population
previously it was just cost prohibitive
to be able to screen large sections of
the population using omics data to try
and identify these kinds of early onset
risk markers but increasingly the
technology that allows us to produce
molecular data which is a Next
Generation sequencing is becoming more
and more affordable accessible easier to
use and therefore widely used around the
world especially in these more advanced
economically Advanced countries and so
we now see the availability of Next
Generation sequencing as a technology
that can help us understand what is
happening at that cellular level how are
these cells dividing how is this DNA
being transcribed and what are the
abnormalities that start accumulating in
different organs and tissues to try and
detect early symptoms in early markers
of increasing risk that these patients
might have now omix data in general
omics means collection and so we can see
omics being used for different types of
data really and that can start from
phenomics where we try to characterize
uh kind of visually how things look
tissues cells in a high throughput way
and then we can look at genomic data
where we sequence The genome or the
whole exome and we see specific
mutations at individual nucleotype
positions that we can try to associate
with abnormalities there's a whole field
of epigenetics where epigenomic data is
being generated increasingly since about
2009 2010 increasingly being informative
because it really helps us understand
the regulation that is not encoded in
the genome is that actually tends to
result in the different levels of gene
expression and then finally
transcriptomics which is where we can
understand the actual expression of
transfer trips and genes which of course
lead to proteomics which are the
proteins being produced from these mRNA
uh
recipes now in addition to these omics
data there's also
vironics
metagenomics and additional types of
omics data that we can discuss but these
are the three most commonly used ones
genomics epigenomics and transcriptomics
and maybe today more and more
metagenomics as well
so transcriptomics is one of those types
of data that is really useful when we
think about what makes a cell phenotype
so a cell phenotype let's say we talk
about tumor versus normal tissue
it is characterized by the proteins that
are being produced inside that cell and
as you know proteins are the result of
the ribosome translating what is written
on the MRNA on the mature Mr messenger
RNA into these structural functional
proteins and as a proxy mRNA transcripts
are a good way to evaluate how is that
happening inside the cell which allows
us to really understand the presence
absence and abundance of these recipes
that are being produced one example of
how transcriptomics is being used is the
ability to detect specific types of
receptors like the Hertz 2 receptor
which could be targeted by these
monoclonal antibodies like crestuzuma so
really this opportunity to understand
the transcription of different types of
mrnas in cells that become tumors or are
tumors helps us understand how we can
more accurately categorize many
different types of cancers and this in
fact has happened already in the field
of breast cancer classification in fact
breast cancer classification has been
developing from about 2010 to 2013 where
we see an introduction of additional
subtypes that are actually categorized
by these molecular profiling and this
molecular profiling is the next step
after histological classification where
clinicians look at how different types
of growths or tumors are contained
within a specific tissue or more
invasive or infiltrating to other
tissues and they can also look at why
that is happening so look deeper at the
molecular profiles and try to understand
that the genomic transcriptomic
proteomic or even metabolomic level how
are these Dynamics changing inside the
cell and a good way to kind of think
about well how has that changed breast
cancer classification is the appearance
or emergence of luminal a luminal b uh
triple negative cancers for example
where we have molecular classification
with specific uh kind of targets like
her2 protein
Etc and even functional classification
to understand what do these cells have
the potential to become and so what that
tells us about the role of
bioinformatics that it plays in this
field is that it really is a very
specific approach that is data driven to
try to understand in the collected data
that is available both in experimental
data and clinical data of how we can
connect the clinical manifestation of
these phenotypes like a disease such as
cancer and its class and stage with the
underlying collection of different types
of omics and maybe even how they are
related together and the ultimate goal
of this is to produce more precise and
more personalized Diagnostics and
Therapeutics so let's take a look at
some examples of the how this has happen
over time
so one of the interesting things about
clinical use of bioinformatics and in
general this kind of uh you know
approach to understand these molecular
changes is that it really doesn't always
make sense for us to start looking at
the population already of clinical
patients A lot of times it starts with
patient-derived cell lines
patient-derived xenograph models or
animal models that have engrafted tumors
in them and then ultimately to try to
use that information coming from cell
lines and animal models to inform a
better decision-making process when it
comes to patients and so what we will do
in this program is take a look at some
of these data sets that can characterize
clinical populations using pre-clinical
models such as animal models or even
experimental data at the cell line level
so what ultimately this might lead to is
how we can use molecular profiling to
produce prognostic Diagnostic and
therapeutic markers biomarkers like
genes or mutations and other molecular
changes to prescribe more precise uh
clinical trials and ultimately treatment
now interestingly enough
over the past few years starting from
maybe 2015 we've seen an emergence of
this new category of on call oncological
drugs Therapeutics that are called
immunotherapy
that are actually today are becoming
more and more effective and even
surpassing chemotherapy the traditional
approach to treatment of cancer
by targeting specific receptors with
monoclonal antibodies
um oftentimes kind of triggering an
immune response so leveraging the immune
response of a healthy individual and one
of those examples as you can see here
keytruda has made a huge kind of change
in this field in 2019 and then we can
see here a specific targeted drug for
the Keras Target and and just recently
in June or July
yes July 2022 we saw this drug does the
limob that demonstrated a hundred
percent complete response rate in the
subset of patients with the MMR rectal
cancer now what's interesting here is
that in this article we read that these
data provide the framework for immune
ablative therapies and highlight the
clinical impact of biomarker driven
therapy in early stage diseases
treatment of the tumor diagnostic DMR
population of early stage diseases has
the potential to eliminate the need for
chemotherapy radiation and surgery in
three to four percent of all cancers
this has the potential to be translated
rapidly into areas around the world
without access to Modern chemotherapy
radiation and therapy so in surgery
sorry and so as you can imagine this has
the potential to really change the way
that we treat cancer diagnose cancer
especially early on
and uh we read here about uh three to
four percent of all cancers uh so um
this is uh an equivalent of
about 28 000 people so it's really a
significant impact
um that will significantly reduce the
cost of treatment uh the ability to
identify patients at risk and to also
improve their outcomes at the same time
now ultimately uh the traditional
approach
um is to try to um kind of go from the
clinical to the research right so a lot
of times the traditional approach is
that we take
um kind of the clinical phenotypes the
most impactful areas where a change
could be made and we start asking
questions you know what could be done
differently but in the modern era there
is an additional approach that is data
driven and that is what I want to focus
on in the next several slides of my
presentation is really talk about how
availability of data that has been
produced by top labs around the world
that have generated sequencing data from
style lines from animal models and from
patients can actually help us shorten
the time from
novel discoveries about page and
subpopulations and subgroups interaction
between comorbidities or different types
of diseases that kind of cause an
ultimate decline in health and the
ability to prescribe new or existing
treatments in the case of drug
repurposing and reposition
so where is this data first of all I I'm
sure that all of you are familiar with
the national Center of biotechnology
information or ncbi where over the past
several decades there had there has been
an exponential growth in the available
data that characterizes different
pathogens individuals animal models
experiments at the molecular level and
this really kind of brought this
Paradigm of Big Data into the field of
clinical research and biomedical
research and so today we have a growing
volume variety value and velocity of
data that is being generated in fact
today we see that the pace of data
generation is much faster than the
ability of labs and and groups that deal
with this kind of research analyze data
and extract meaningful insights and what
I mean by that is not the ability to
produce reports you know not clinical
reporting on significant variants but
people who are trained to look at data
ask questions and find indications in
the data sets that could help us answer
some of these questions that are so
important and burning for for patients
that have only months to live
one of the important projects in this
field in the field of oncology has been
the tcga or the cancer genome Atlas
the cancer Genome of Atlas provides a
unique opportunity to see multiple types
of Onyx data combined together to
describe approximately 13 different
types of cancer and this covers over 30
000 cases
with data that is available for pretty
much anyone to analyze so here you can
see an example of some of those clinical
characterizations of patients of course
these patients are de-identified so you
have their ID only but you can actually
see uh different types of
characteristics like comorbidities in
this case this is a liver cancer
population of liver cancer patients but
you can see hepatitis
age BMI obesity and other factors and
interestingly enough you also have a
guide on how to effectively use such
data and actually leverage some of the
novel computational techniques to to be
able to extract meaningful insights from
molecular and clinical data that is
provided across these different types of
cancer now as I mentioned
there are many different types of cancer
described or characterized in this
project but specifically when it comes
to hepatocellular carcinoma or liver
cancer we can see that the variety of
omics data from exome sequencing to copy
number variation to mRNA sequencing or
transcriptomics to microorganasic
methylomics and even proteomics we can
start finding significantly mutated
genes over Amplified genes integrated
subgroup classifiers or how can we use
these markers to identify specific
patient populations and additional
insights that are critical to being able
to treat one of these dominant cancers
that are actually emerging in Asia in
the Far East
so interestingly um they are both
user-friendly tools and tools that are
more kind of computational algorithms to
be able to identify
these data but I think uh the
availability of this data has really
brought about the awareness of how this
publicly available data could be used
both by clinicians and researchers but
also by by citizen scientists that are
able to find interesting insights and
kind of develop further some ideas that
could be proved based on real world
evidence and that's another another
important project in this field is the
new kind of variation of genomic
projects called the all of us research
Hub a new program by the National
Institutes of Health here in the us
where we can see
again different conditions across a
variety of medical Concepts drug
exposures different types of medical
characterizations and procedures so a
lot of clinical data coupled with
genomic variants and an additional type
of data including by the way
transcriptomic and management data that
is being generated and all of this data
is becoming more and more accessible
which is the really exciting part I
think for those of us who are in this
meeting now in addition to that we also
have the NIH human microbiome project
which again has over 30 000 individuals
that have metagenomic 16s ribosomal RNA
sequencing available for them and allows
us to understand the correlation between
microbiome variation at the taxonomic
level with different types of clinical
and pre-clinical phenotypes for example
exercise age diet even ethnicity and
things like that
so it's really an exciting time to be in
bioinformatics whether you are a
bioinformed Edition or clinician or a
biologist because ultimately
availability of data is what has been
preventing many from really applying
their skills and understanding of data
science methods and algorithms to
extract interesting insights for those
of us that are not as familiar with what
could be done what we will do over the
course of this program is use case study
approach that helps us understand how
experts in the field from companies like
Genentech from research Labs like MD
Anderson and even from Clinical use
cases on how to use such data to address
some of the pressing needs in the field
of precision medicine from oncology to
neurosciences to other applications as
well now you might look at this and you
might think that this sounds fairly
complex and and I agree bioinformatics
is complex not only do you have to
understand the terminology you have to
be able to apply technical engineering
skills on data acquisition processing
then analysis visualization Etc to be
able to answer some of these questions
and for many biologists that kind of
looks like this right we're overwhelmed
with new two ideas like deep learning
and different types of visual techniques
that tend to show something that is only
meaningful to engineers and not really
to biologists and so what I want to say
is that this specific program is really
not about that I think we will have a
glimpse of that for those of you who are
interested but primarily we want to make
this as user friendly as possible and so
for that purpose I want to introduce you
to one of the resources that you will
have accessible during this program
which is the T bioinformer platform now
the platform really breaks down some of
this algorithmic complexity and allows
you to build visual interactive
pipelines with every step of the way
clearly explained with inputs and
outputs that you will recognize from
some of the Publications that you
probably read and understand and has a
direct link to the biology that you're
interested in now along the way we will
use some of the methods for uh analyzing
annotating and interpreting the results
of data analysis using a user-friendly
interface and focusing on the
relationship between the data and the
interpretation of the analysis results
and ultimately introducing you to the
potentials that that some of these
complex algorithms like Data Mining and
classification can have for those of us
who are interested to make an impact in
these data driven areas of precision
medicine research and translational and
clinical research now over the past uh
couple of years at least maybe two or
three years now uh everybody has been
talking about infectious diseases and
not anymore uh oncology on its own so we
will also take a look at some examples
from uh infectious diseases where we
will take a look at some outbreak
dynamics that could be characterized
with omics data again genomics and
transcriptomics and we will take a look
at several examples like the Ebola
outbreak of
2015-2016 the current pandemic that is
uh kind of still going on with covet but
also some other types of applications of
microbiome analysis that can help us
understand the association between
infectious diseases caused by viruses
bacteria and other types of pathogens
and how the response of the immune
response the markers of the immune
response can help us identify five
patients that are at most risk or the
best targets for a specific type of
intervention
now all of this is just to say that as
you learn about the methods of data
analysis and the key here is the logic
of data analysis you will then be able
to think how those types of analyzes
that you've learned and maybe applied to
a specific case study could be
applicable in the Clinica as well so let
me tell you a few examples of how this
could be used classification
is a domain in machine learning where we
have annotated data which helps us
identify based on new data that we
generate about a patients a specific uh
group that that patient can fall under
and some applications include clinical
as well as Farmland biotech so for
clinical this could be used for patient
stratification like grouping patients by
risk levels disease classification and
Diagnostics
identification of potential responders
to therapies and understanding of
mechanisms of action or mechanisms of
disease onset and progression and then
in Pharma biotech a lot of their focus
is on discovery of biomarkers right so
we just saw an example in an article how
this kind of biomarker guided treatment
options are going to revolutionize the
way immune immunotherapy is used that
even eliminate the need for other types
of treatments like chemotherapy and
surgery also detection of toxicity at
the end vitro stage so one of the drugs
that we saw there it is very promising
and it has the potential to really
affect the this large sized population
but the problem is that it could have
side effects and that it's not going to
be useful for everyone and so
unfortunately when there's a promise of
efficacy there's also a danger of
toxicity and if we could identify the
toxicity in patients at the in vitro
stage that would ultimately lead to
elimination of a lot of waste and
actually an opportunity to focus energy
and resources on more promising uh drugs
analysis of molecular mechanism of a
drug action or targeted Discovery a big
field where we are seeing a lot of
pharmaceutical companies kind of uh
going through the FDA approval process
and identifying that not only do we know
that this drug works but this is its
biological mechanism of action
increasingly the mechanism of action is
at the molecular level
and then finally drug repurposing oral
repositioning so all of these
applications are applications of
classification and that is one of the
methods that you can Master very quickly
by going through some of the case
studies and examples that we will
introduce throughout this program
now for those of you who are interested
um these user-friendly tools are going
to be coupled with scripting and coding
so you could learn how to implement some
of those methods on your own and the
outcome here is to help you build out a
portfolio that can illustrate how you
can apply these skills effectively and
build out your own set of projects and
that will be driven by tutorials and
coding exercises that you can follow
online on our portal so to summarize by
joining this program we hope that every
participant will have the ability to
understand scientific literature that
understand that describes analysis of
homics data we'll be able to perform
basic processing steps for Next
Generation data Next Generation
sequencing data analysis perform
exploratory analysis and generate a
hypothesis from data or data driven
research design contrast for statistical
tests and prepared data for machine
learning annotate found signal using
biological databases and references
identify appropriate data sets for
answering a biological question and plan
a bioinformatics analysis from start to
finish independently now for some of you
and maybe not all I think an additional
bonus is being able to present a project
proposal including the rationale method
scientific background and anticipated
results and if you are at that stage
where you design a project proposal we
will then present you with additional
opportunities to work with mentors that
you could leverage to actually complete
that analysis and leverage that project
in your next research clinical biotech
or even Innovative entrepreneurial
application
now many students from around the world
have completed such training and
importantly if you come from a research
background you will be seeing how it's
easy to take what you have learned and
apply it to an area where you already
are applying your you know research
skills or participating in interesting
projects and this was the case with olgo
direct service she now works for a
pharmaceutical company but back then she
was a postdoc at the Roswell Park
Comprehensive Cancer Center and was able
to apply the tools that she has learned
to her own research as well
I want to conclude with a brief overview
of program resources what do you get by
joining this particular program you will
have access to training materials that
are both asynchronous and live just like
what we're doing now
uh as I mentioned a lot of learning will
be focused on the logic first so you'll
understand the connection between these
important Concepts and application of
these Concepts to real world challenges
but if you are interested in we will
provide you with all of the source code
as well and train you on how to develop
a Jupiter notebook of your own data
analysis process using R and Python and
then finally all of the sessions will be
recorded and available to you even after
the program is over
uh over the course of this uh program we
will be relying on the T bioinfo
platform which allows large-scale
analysis visualization and integration
of omics data and this includes
different sections for
genomic data like whole genome or whole
exome data
transcriptomic data epigenomic data
proteomic metagenomic and even viramic
and and the goal is to allow you to
quickly process
analyze and visualize this data and even
generate interactive dashboards that you
can then use to present what you have
found
um after testing uh this uh platform
with many users we find that the
majority find it mostly or extremely
useful
and importantly it is built around
technologies that are scalable and
applicable Beyond just the learning that
you will see in this program
researchers from Top institutions have
been using the platform to analyze their
own data and institutions like Oregon
State University the Mayo Clinic or
University of California San Francisco
and as I mentioned one of the key
features is that you understand the
logic of analysis and are able to apply
this logic in a visual reproducible way
to extract meaningful insights now these
kinds of applications are important
because it really simplifies and
shortens the path to Discovery and
ranges from simple or fairly simple data
sets to increasingly complex including
methods like single cell analysis
metagenomics and meta transcriptomics
genomic data analysis with
characterization of individual mutations
uh and data mining and machine learning
which we already talked about being used
increasingly in this field now what we
prefer to do is not just teach you kind
of tutorial style where here's the
problem here's the code here's what you
need to do but instead focus on case
studies and so we'll use these examples
extracting the abstract from
Publications that had an impact in this
field and allowing you to understand how
the terms explained in those articles
are linked to actual data analysis
techniques that you can both learn about
and practice
and I want to mention that you can start
with all of this today so
even if you are not able to participate
in the program we invite you today to
join the portal
um and so I briefly want to go to the
portal and and show you how you can
register and sign up so the portal link
is learn omnixlogic.com I will paste the
link in the chat
right here you can register for free and
create a free account
um so you can go to login
um you can use uh sign up right here you
can create an account right here on this
portal
and I will be able to use my existing
login
to
go into my profile
so once you have created your profile
you can then complete it by adding your
profile picture social media links and a
brief bio
and as you go through the different
training Parts in this program or
asynchronously you will see your
progress being mentioned under the
courses your certificates being added to
this tablet right here and today you
will be able to join the programs that
we have
so the program once you've signed up the
program is going to be available
um
I think
yep so we have the link in the chat
this is the program itself and you can
see here
how all of the information is available
today we had the webinar so you could
learn more and share this with others in
your network
and you can also start looking at the
schedule that we have for this program
once you go through the details and
understand the schedule you can see some
of the resources that are available
and select the level that you're more
interested in which is based on the time
frame that you will have access to all
of these resources as well as some
additional features like access to
mentors and working on an independent
research proposal and actually
completing your research project as well
and here you will see some of the case
studies that will be available during
this program
so at this point I'm going to open up
the questions so if you have any
questions please do let us know in the
chat
um let me stop the